it's Tuesday the 16th of January the
checkin is brought to you by my favorite
liquid IV new year new you it's time to
drink something other than booze and get
your hydration on point liquid IV lets
you rehydrate easily just pour the
packet into a glass of water Shake It Up
and that's it liquid IV comes in tons of
awesome flavors my favorite is golden
cherry I love the grape they got sugar
and lemon lime white peach and the green
grape will knock you off your [__]
socks liquid IV is ready to take you
from a dehydrated mess to a brand new
you I get up in the morning I blast off
a liquid ieni before I drink coffee to
get all the spirits out of my system and
I'm ready to go so R 2024 is the year to
rehydrate yourself so do yourself a
favor grab liquid IV hydration
multiplier sugarfree in both nationwide
at Costco who I love or I'm going to get
you 20% off your first order when you go
to liquid i.com use code Joey and
checkout that's 20% off your first order
when you shop better hydration today
using promo code Joey at liquid
i.com again liquid.com code Joey the
checkin is also brought to you by factor
maybe you wait like trash in December
well that was last year and this is this
year Jack we got a whole new thing going
on eat well with Factor the meal kit
that does all the work for you no
grocery shopping no chopping vegetables
no piles of dirty dishes to deal with
Factor sends you a fresh restaurant
quality meal right to your doorstep all
you got to do is heat them up for two
minutes that's it and they're ready to
eat they're tremendous they have over 35
meals to choose from every week vegan
vegetarian k options and more this
beat's eating three-day old meal prep
casserole trust me what I'm telling you
so Factor even has snacks you can take
with you breakfast smoothies and juices
to keep you going all day head over to
factor meals.com that's factor meals.com
and use Diaz 50 and I'm Gonna Get You
50% off that's right that's code
diaz5 at Factor meals.com
Diaz 50 to get
50% off the checkin is also brought to
you by B bam bluechew listen it's time
to go to Vegas and bust a nut Jack you
know what I'm saying it's bluechew time
for you Savages bluechew is an online
service that delivers Ed medicine with
the same AC ingredients as Viagra seis
and Levitra right to your door they come
in chewable tablets tremendous just pop
one 30 to 60 minutes before getting down
and dirty and forget about it that
muffler will be completely different you
can take them any time breakfast lunch
dinner and it's easy to get a
prescription just sign at blu.com and
talk to one of the licensed medical
providers and you'll get your
prescription within days blueo wants to
have you have better sex all right
that's it they want you to be a [__]
Savage so discover your options at
bluechew.com chew it and do it Jack and
get a special deal for the check-in
listeners you ready try blue Chu for
free it's free it's [__] Tuesday I'm
hooking you up Preston Cod Joey Joe y at
checkout just pay $5 for shipping that's
blu.com promo code Joey to receive your
first month free visit blu.com for more
details and important safety information
and I want to thank him for sponsoring
to check it let's get ready to rock turn
off your TVs run for your lives it's
over they didn't put you on this planet
just to give up if Uncle Joey could do
it I can rule the world that's what you
got to be thinking welcome back
[Music]
to
what's the story dog it's good to see
you buddy good to see you [__]
Tuesday the 16th we're already past the
[__] halfway mark it's over that's it
it's been going it snowed yesterday it's
gonna snow tomorrow it's [__] win
tonight it's gonna [__] Let It Snow
dog that's a you know people are like oh
it's gonna it's [__] January what do
you expect what the [__] you think is
going to happen you know the sun's going
to come in people G to be dancing with
[__] bikinis no it's it doesn't get
higher than maybe 50 if you're [__]
lucky you know I know do you see what's
going on like Nashville and Texas it
looks crazy like they don't know how to
do it like I think I got like Stu finer
was flying into Nashville today and he
got his flight got cancel they got like
eight inches in Nashville oh yeah that's
you know it's [__] January it's not
like it happened in [__] June right
it's January they're telling you it's
gonna be a [__] snowy
January [__] I can't stand it how was
your week my week was [__] fantastic
bro it's getting better and better uh
I'm a it's just been good L just the
last four weeks or so it's just been
[__] Dynamite like it really has been
I'm sticking to my schedule I got on
stage last week again you know so when I
do those little things I always feel
better about myself just little things
Little Steps become big steps started
out the book the new comedy book with
Erica you know we're gonna hook up
tomorrow
again so uh yeah I can't complain man
been getting a lot of [__] sleep been
smoking good
reefer did you get more delivery of that
kind you you got last time oh I got a
different batch today today I got
white something white
gumbo Jesus I I was Tip Top M go at 4:15
today I was doing jump I did a lot of
[__]
today I smoked three bong hits of it
next thing you know had to take an hour
and nap oh that's best bring groceries
up the steps for my wife I brought them
up and I'm like you know what I got to
take a little [__] afternoon Siesta
and I quick hour got up ate some
medibles Bing Bang Boom and here we are
how and I know you just started but like
it have you noticed the difference in
like the writing process since you
already wrote tremend mendous like is it
easier this
time
well it's all fitting together the
reason why I want listen the night that
I fell on my ankle that same night I was
coming home to go to an open mic here
that's they do like twice a month and
one of my buddies from Jiu-Jitsu told me
about it and I was know that it was a
big surprise and then I hurt myself that
night I couldn't do nothing for three or
4 weeks then the holidays were comeing I
said [__] it I won't start it till
January and the reason why was because I
want to write this book and for me to
write this book I gotta be in touch with
what I was in touch with 30 years ago I
don't know how I'm going to do it but
the beautiful thing about this is It's
Time the first time I got up I did five
minutes the second time I doubled it
with like [__] 10 you know so I got
something else I want to add
tonight and it's just a process and
that's what people will never
understand that way before we pop on a
podcast on LA or with Rogan or with CA
or with Berke ker we go through [__]
hell they just think we came out of the
Grave one day and started doing comedy
and that was before we met you there was
15 years of [__] confinement you know
what I'm saying yeah I feel like I'm in
that hell right now it just but I
there's a difference between like being
funny on stage and being funny on a
podcast
what what are you [__] yeah yeah
there's a big [__] difference a big
difference what you just figured that
out now no it's just different man like
it's with standup like you get to
practice it and and then like you know
refine it try different words on a
podcast usually at least the kind we do
it's just whatever we're thinking about
in the moment okay let's
say how many
podcasters you have to say any names or
whatever I'm just you know there's a
couple podcasts that got into this and
because of the podcast they sprung into
comedy it's the next level and they've
developed in front of their audience
they're not the best standups in the
world but they play to Their audience
and and so there's two thoughts there
when I write this book I'm not talking
about podcast I ain't talking about
roller
skating this is
standup you know right I was thinking
about what hell is the other day you
know for some
people and what hell is for a comic okay
a comic will move you will leave your
house right now your home you will leave
your girlfriend you know and you'll move
to I'm just throwing names here you're
gonna move to in New York Austin or
whatever as a comic now you know there's
some people that have a little bit of
money there's some people that go
listen when I moved to LA I had
$250 [__] expenses okay so once you
[__] hook up with something they're
gonna go yeah you could stay on my floor
for a month until you get on your feet
and you know your grandmother sends you
money you [__] get a little part-time
gig you don't want to because you
[__] doing you're you're an artist
you're doing comedy the only problem
with artists is they got thrown out of a
lot of [__] apartments and they break
a lot of leases and there's credit
problems that's the that's the serious
problem about being a [__] artist
because I was thinking about this I was
in
Seattle I was living in a house that had
a dog and the dog would [__] in any room
he wanted
to my bedroom fac the [__] highway
there was no air conditioner there was a
fan you know my
bedroom the TV stunk like
that but why did the TV stink no the TV
room stunk like
that were all old and [__] and you know
I don't know what I was paying there but
I know I couldn't afford the
rent but I found happiness because I had
three sets that
night right and one of them was a paid
gig for $50 not that it was even gonna
get me close to the rent so why even
try you know d That's [__] hell for a
regular person
that's heaven for a
com was it hard for you to go from you
know like stealing and drugs even like
even like selling cars to having no
money yeah because even when I was
selling I had been broke
Le I went over my everything like by
93 I was flat broke when I came to New
York and then in New York I got my
hustling game back on I was dropping
phone pH packages I was picking up Coke
in the city for people I was you know
selling insurance on the phone I did a
thousand things I picked up a job doing
a limo and coming back here got me in
that Hustlers mood again I had been
Bolder for God knows how long and I got
back into it and doing the open mics in
New York helped me figure it out but
when I was here in 93 I shared a bedroom
with a
man okay he was my best friend he's my
brother and he's still my brother
George he slept on the couch and I slept
on a [__] kids bed we had a
fan you know it wasn't uh we lived with
his
grandmother that's not that's not when
you tell a girl when you're
33 and what is that like being because
you like being your 30s you're 30 your
friends are already established they're
getting married they're having kids and
here you are sleeping in a [__]
bedroom with a man with no
TV you know no air conditioner just a
fan but I was [__] happy as [__]
because I was doing comedy I was writing
I was wearing a suit half the day the
other half I had jeans on it it was a
superb nine months of
training then you get used to it you're
like this is how I'm going to live from
now one and You' be surprised again as
long as you keep doing those sets people
invite you over to eat the bartender
will go hey I I ordered spaghetti I
don't want the rest of it you want it do
I want
it and let me get the rest of those
olives that for the martinis I don't
care they're day I'll pops some olives
in that spaghetti you it's [__] crazy
what we think Heaven is is a
comic and and like it could be hell for
like a regular for not a regular person
person but just someone else someone who
doesn't have that dream someone who
doesn't have that logic when your
brother comes to visit you and you're in
a house with eight guys and the house
smells like [__]
doom and you know you got a beat up
car you know the the guy's girlfriend
lives there she's been stabbed you and
he's like Lee what are you doing and
you're like I'm doing comedy man I'm
happy and they're like are you [__]
because they don't see that they don't
nobody will see that oh so you're they
was there was people that used to go out
of that way to go oh you did comedy last
night what you
make and they thought being cute yeah I
for your first question yeah like what'
you make last night like people were
trying to be cute you know and I would
it didn't matter what I made it didn't
[__] matter I didn't care about
making money I cared about being
funny I didn't care about my
health you know I ate whatever was in
front of me if I didn't need I didn't e
if I had cash I ate good if I didn't
have C you know it's a [__] jungle of
a life but you know you're working for
something it's like going into the army
and wanting to be a [__] sniper you
know you got to go through three [__]
Wars it's it's it's uh it's not the life
people want to
choose you know right when you look at
the first 10
years and it was it was f i T to you a
little bit about this weekend but I was
having breakfast with Josh this weekend
and he was telling me about when you
guys were caterers in Seattle and like
you said he said you s a trash can on
fire you know listen man it was one of
those NBC something in the
afternoon I forget what street that was
Larch Mount you know what Larch Mount is
it goes straight down if oh this is in
La okay this was in LA yeah so if you go
back to [__] La if you hit Santa
Monica you could only make a left or
right there there's a straight building
off a Larch Mount okay MC was having
like some type of party it's got to
be
98 you know I'm sleeping on couches I'm
doing sets at the store Josh gets me
some catering gigs I get a couple gigs
on my own you know it was just you're
just surviving and we did this catering
and it was Gentiles everybody was too
cool you know and all of a sudden it was
like we had a catada like from 12 like
11 to 2 it was like 11: to 2:30 and Josh
had to leave to pick up his [__] kids
right so we wrapping up and they're like
well you have to take the oil and walk
down the block and drain it I'm like
what I'm not walking down no block with
a kettle of oil I just get Josh get it
let's dip it in the garbage and I throw
it in the gar garbage and all sudden the
[__] garbage can starts melting and
Flames shoot out of it and you know me
dog I don't know nothing I just keep
talking like it's nothing people like
fire
fire gosh let's get out of here and that
was the end of
it did anyone ever say anything to you
nothing they called like an hour later
were you there not I don't know I don't
know what happened there was combustible
material in the [__] I don't
know I didn't I didn't care that was not
my job right that's what gonna say comic
I'm a comic if you want to give me 50
bucks to come here and serve food that's
your problem I'm not gonna be the best
server you know I'm not gonna have a
Caso on what could I get you [__] you
get it yourself you [__] peasant I'm
gonna
[__] oh is
it the joy I found in that part of my
life
to the Joy I found going on the road
every week and people lighting your
cigarettes it was two different worlds
the latter one I would didn't enjoy as
the early one all that walking in LA and
shoplifting packs of cigarettes and
sleeping on Josh's couch and [__]
some night you get lucky and sleep at
her house and you [__] steal a box of
[__] cereal for breakfast it's a
different
world but it's it's weird like not not
weird it's it's nice that you that you
liked it but it's just it's a scary
thing to think about it's a scary thing
to think to to think about having no
money for a lot of people it's
scary how many people get 990,000 a year
and hate that [__] job a lot of
people how about I give you a job that
you're not getting paid but you do it
for free every [__] night and you
know what I'm looking at you right now
if I said to you listen listen I got a
[__] tour a [__] Antiga tickets to
$10 I'm going to take care of your
expenses all your meals you're not gonna
need for anything Lee but I can't pay
you but it's four weeks we're just gonna
every night six nights oh okay that's a
[__] summer camp for me and you like
we tell everybody ma see you later I'm
going to summer even though it's going
to be hell you're going to have to sleep
in the room with a sound guy you know
you have to smell his feet he's
farting but even at night when you lay
down you're like this is
crazy but you know what I did really
good tonight yeah I don't know and I'm I
this is like the first time it's
happened but because I'm not like a
really I'm I'm kind of a reserved person
but I did really well on Saturday and I
just I found myself like kind of dancing
like once I got off St like I don't know
I just I I it was just I was walking
over to my stuff and I just sort of like
strut it over it like I don't like the
confidence that you have or at least
that I have when like I do
well I just I I I I was literally just
dancing as the music was playing for
Josh to go on
stage you know it's so much I love when
you call me at the end of your nights
when I'm not sleeping already and we get
to
chitchat and I could tell that happiness
in your voice and that happiness is what
I'm talking about like as comedians we
don't think like most people most people
are like hi Lee it's Sunday let's go
shopping what would you like to dinner
this week and you're like you know what
Wednesday I want meatloaf and [__]
Thursday I want
lockers Comics don't do that real Comics
are like listen I'm living for
today I is that cuz you were have you
were you like that before comedy like
you didn't not that you didn't plan CU
you always planned but like you just
didn't really if someone asked you what
you were doing in a
week like you don't really do that I do
but I don't I have anchors everybody has
anchors every day there's something that
you have to do every day and then you
build your day around that for us it's a
job right it's working for most
Americans it's working for us it's
writing
it's writing but then it's also like I
I'm at a place at least where like right
now it's started to get out a little bit
but for the most part like I people ask
me to do a show like week of two weeks
out this is the game this is what I said
to you ain't nobody gonna call you and
say October 24th that not in your world
right now right you're gonna get at the
end of the year you're gonna look at all
your notebook and see your
work 50% of it was planned I guarantee
the other another 50% you got the week
up you picked up on Monday you know know
how many times I'll talk to a real comic
and they'll go I just got one week at
the end of the
month and then a week later I'm on
Instagram and I see them in
Minnesota down I'm like that's a real
comic he picked up a
Fallout right it's amazing once you put
your heart into
it the calls you start getting I told
you I went on the road with a friend of
mine
we had four weeks booked we ended up
doing
10 oh you just got it while you were on
the road on the road calling people hey
man we're close by we're gonna be in
your neighborhood next week what do you
got well I got a a feature an MC perfect
I'm bringing a girl with
me we'll take it yeah 350 for you and
150 for her what are you gonna do it's a
hotel for three nights I get to do
laundry I get to eat with a discount out
and I get to make some
money that's how you look at
it and then Sunday morning you wake up
and you're ready to leave and all sudden
you got a club from the the call from
the booker going hey where are you are
you still there good what do you got
next week and you're like I got a
Thursday night show at Taco Bell and
[__] Arvada and he was like
listen stay there I'll pay for your
hotel tonight and Monday head out to
Idaho do the Boise run for me it's five
nights and you're like okay I just went
from picking up $75 in a free Taco to
500 bucks in a hotel room for three days
that three days in the hotel meanwhile
I'm in my car I'm looking for a $20
hotel room usually the hotels where you
stay at in those little States like that
they'll say to you if you stay the extra
night we'll just charge you half the
rate
38 bucks or $44 it's better than the
80 yeah I got [__] they a hotel in uh
Richmond because I went the night before
charged me for two nights it's like it's
like did did people try to [__] with you
and like and I I was just thinking
because I'm lucky enough to be able to
pay for it if I was broke and someone
charged an extra 150 to my credit card I
would be pissed your head blows up
people have no idea you're expecting to
pick up cash to hit you with a [__]
check you know there's so many variables
that's part of the game the end of the
night when you going to get paid they go
oh your agent didn't tell you we're
mailing you a check overnight you'll get
it Tuesday and you're like how the [__]
am I getting
back [__] there's just so many [__]
things but at the end of the day they're
always
fun every in a while you got a reality
check you have to spend the night at
Greyhound you know with some old guy
next to you looking at your shoes and
[__] and [__] you know eating [__]
you know you're on a 12-h hour bus ride
and all you're eating is [__] junk
Le yeah you're eating
garbage and it's just it's a you know I
look at though the other day Coke case
was on for the last
year codas is on every [__] day I
don't know what
time I don't okay and every once in a
while I'll catch it it's on and I'll put
it on to see if it was Disco
Inferno which one that the co-case it's
an old show on CBS oh I know that show
but what's Disco Inferno it's an episode
yeah this Corno was my guest my first
guest star ever oh [__] what year was
that
2003 I swear to God I booked that it
doesn't matter just want to give you an
example the other night I'm sitting
there and I'm ready to go upstairs and I
scroll and there it is Disco and ferle
so I put it on
Le when I first came on screen I just
turned the TV
off really just turned it
off I turned it off and I sat there for
20 minutes thinking about that
day and what had happened was I booked
that show on December
18th and I left for Houston Texas on
like the
20th and that's when I used to do the
two weeks before Christmas in Houston he
would headline me the guy because he
liked me and he paid me good money for
then you know right and I do the two
weeks go leading up to New Year's and
then Gaffin would come in and I'd go to
La and do New Year's with Rogan at The
Improv or the we do we do The Comedy
Store last we would do something at 8
and 10 so that was my schedule I went
down to [__] Houston on the
20th and I came back I was like 24
pounds
heavier in two weeks bro when I went to
put wardrobe on the [__] I had tried on
for an hour for wardrobe two weeks
earlier did not fit me my stomach was B
when you see this episode you will
[__] die my stomach was bulging
through the shirt that was two weeks of
[__] doing
powder drinking Jager Meister a bottle
of night we were drinking in that bar at
the lap stop he would go through a
bottle of night after the show just from
you or like all the comics everybody six
seven shots five
shots then I was waking up I was going
to that [__] Greek place and he would
make me the biggest egg omelette cheese
omelet you'd ever seen in your life he'd
give me like six pieces of wheat toast
buttered and a separate dish of crinkle
cut french
fries and I'd be drinking coca-colas the
whole time and that was every morning
that was every morning in Houston or or
I would get up and get
Kachi like 10 of them with a can of
donuts right like donuts with sausages
in them or something in them and some
days I would go get a breakfast and then
make him stop at the Kachi Factory and
get [__] a dozen kachis and [__] and
then fanch were're hitting anti anti
Woos anti whatever's dumpling Palace we
were killing it in there fried rice why
are you allowed to eat Chinese food in
Texas because this was a good place this
was in Houston I don't think there any
good now but back then they made really
good pork fried rice a decent soup
the dumplings were okay you know not
nothing like what we get with steady
Freddy right or [__] this place
no but uh yeah that's that was my lunch
either that place or
Papados [__] that's a that's a good two
weeks but you put on how much weight do
you think you put on I told you 20
[__] six pounds 20 20 pound 23 PBS
something like that to the point where
my shirt didn't fit Le
like I went from like that's the time I
went from like
350 to 379 or something like
that what did wardrobe say they were
like what
happened like it was [__] week in or
two weeks in Houston two weeks in
Houston no sleep drugs no water zero
exercise zero exercise the only exercise
was walking to the club walking to the
to the bathroom to do Coke you
know what a sad [__] life but that
was that was part of the comedy it was
all it all it was part of the
gig you know it was Jimmy Paige's
birthday last week he turned 80 okay I'm
like how the [__] is this guy 80 you
know 45 years ago this guy was hooked on
Heroin that he was a
skeleton you know and I'm like wow
listen
man you know I I guess the body
heals the Mind
heals those uh from when I got into
comedy it gave me Freedom it gave me no
responsibility I didn't have to get up
anymore yeah you you it was just
yourself and then when I moved to LA I
thought it was going to calm down it
[__] just
expanded you know your career or the or
your health well the health and the the
drug use and the drinking and the
[__] whatever came with it you know
speaking of drug use I found a video
this weekend that I I I I have to show
you Andy could you show Joey the video
that I found it might be the best thing
I've ever seen on
YouTube I got to put glasses on are you
here the me
[__] and crackhead chuing
comp here we go it's a crackhead
chucking
competition that's black on black crime
DG wait till you see this one look at
this look at the muscles on this guy and
the guy just lets him throw
him
and then the guy comes over to like
measure it oh my
[Music]
God throw the crackhead it's the
crackhead chucking competition oh my God
and they're they're in the projects and
the guy has no shirt on he threw them 23
feet n inches would you ever if that was
your salute to Martin Luther King
Day [__] done you know what I'm
saying if that was what you dug up on
Mont Luther King
day I didn't dig it up four Martin
Luther King day but Jesus Christ you're
gonna get me [__] banned from the
airwaves
whyp will be boycotting as soon as [__]
Martin Luther King you couldn't show
people black people marching and dancing
and having a good time a [__]
crackhead chucking contest Martin Luther
King is spinning in his [__] grave
right now oh well you I don't think you
like the marching videos so who the I
don't I don't think you would have liked
the marging videos I like anything any
but the last video you showed us was a a
dude letting a firecracker in his
eyeball so yeah Mar Luther King day it
wasn't June 19th you know what I'm
saying it might have been you don't know
no I show it to you on a Tuesday in
May I love that video holy [__] do you
like did you ever run in like what's the
difference with a crackhead like had you
ever run into someone who would let you
do that to them for money or do any like
did you run into like any crazy people
out
there the craziest thing I ever ran into
was I met a girl in a Miami I forget the
name of this place they had a great
breakfast they had a great Bar Miami
News or
something it used to be 50 yards from
the condo okay started talking and I
could see that she was doing blow and I
go I got a p i got some powder and she
goes I have some tool
whatever and I all right let's get some
beers and get out of here and we went to
the condom we talked a little bit you
know I had dirty thoughts and her
thoughts were dirty
too and she looked at me and she goes if
you could stand on your head against the
wall I'll have sex with you
tonight and the Lord knows I
tried how many times did you try like
three and she grabbed a bag and
left she actually left yeah but she left
the cocaine so I didn't give a [__]
perfect I locked the door and put the
chain on it you know what I'm saying you
ain't coming back
in holy [__] if you can do a a
handstand Lee comedy comedy when you get
into the you
know I was outlining this chapter I was
looking at it and I had to put it in the
book about the universe okay
okay when you get into comedy you really
really have to know that the universe is
watching you're getting into a Karma
business you're getting into
a you know you're getting into a weird
business it's not being a a carpenter an
IT Tech this is all based on your
performance and what you do nobody could
get on stage for you you know right
nobody can do the work for you here you
could can get all the head shots you
want
you could be on all the podcast you want
you can make all the videos you want but
nobody's going to do that work for you
it's 20 sets a month to 50 did you see
Dean Del list his sets yeah he has like
500 he has yeah he does it every year
for like every year he's done standup
this is all important so you know you
did the work so 10 20 years from now
when you're taking a $10,000 week gig
and people downstairs are working for
[__] 10 bucks an hour you don't beat
yourself up you go whoa whoa wait a
second for this long I ate [__] ass
for this long I suffered for this long
when everybody else was jumping up and
down I didn't do that I didn't have the
money or the means so I decided to
work and that gives you peace of
mind you just didn't go to Hollywood and
suck the dick and some guy put you on a
show I did stand up for a year I didn't
really know yeah you know did you know
what you did you know it's it's so weird
I always wanted to know I did the work
and I always wanted to be I wanted to
remind myself I did the
work you know last three years very the
first two years that I CAU here were
very hard but the last year and a half I
I processed that I did the
work I did the work I controlled my
destiny I walked out on my own two
feet but I always did the work I did the
work before I got to the store and I put
on double the work when I got into the
store we were talking about you being
tired last Sunday and we were talking
about what my hours used to be and I
would be you know I'd get home on a
Sunday at [__]
9: sleep for two hours and then be ready
for you 7 o'clock on Sunday with 2,000
more
Edibles yeah I can't imagine jumping off
of a podcast there was never a night off
the podcast no there was never an AA
podcast there was never a sober podcast
there was
nothing podcast no we got especially
when you were touring like like I don't
know like the last couple years not that
you weren't touring hard but you had
started doing theaters a little bit but
like when you were doing weekends at
clubs the whole time I think the first
seven years of the podcast we didn't
even take off for Christmas no we were
working it and and guys we were at a
different level and we were still
working it and you were watching me and
you you know I appreciate that you were
[__] like you know and my days were I
had my workouts done for the week when I
would take that plane on Thursday I had
everything done sometimes I would lift
weights on Thursday morning get on the
plane and tighten up and then I would
walk off the plane like [__] Iron Man
and I oh and now I'm in Gate you know
you know you're it's the only it's the
last FL the [__] day and you're on
gate 2000 you got to walk 10 miles to
get you to the [__] train which you
know people have no idea what it's like
to wake up in Detroit airport and think
you're in the Twilight Zone you're still
buzzing from last night those Edibles
are still kicking through your [__]
system and you're walking under the
airport with lights on and pictures of
whales and lights turning colors and
you're
like dog it's too [__] early for this
did you ever have I had it this weekend
he was very nice so I didn't say
anything but I just I always have you in
my head it was I got picked up at 5: in
the morning to go to the airport and the
Uber guy was very nice but it was a half
an hour ride and he talked for 29
minutes of it and I just because
whenever I start a conversation with
them you're like shut the [__] up like
did you ever have like what would you do
in that situation do you tell them to
like be like hey man I don't too tired I
open the
window if it's cold you open the window
you look out the window
and it gets cold in that [__] car and
he starts like do you want me to turn
the heat on no not really
just not really and they usually get the
the message let's not
chat you could put like something on
there on Uber that I don't want to talk
to the driver I think that's the rudest
[__] thing in the world I would never
do that it was just it was 5: in the
morning and I went to at three so I like
I was just like no ain't no chitty
chatty he don't know that you know just
tell him listen I got in that three I
did some battery acid last night I'm
just coming down I don't know if your
name is Hugo or moo it don't matter
we're taking this [__] to the
next level here you know I I look at the
comedy's fun man yeah comedy's fun with
you with your peers and you build the
best thing about being a young
comic is the peers that you you
know like with you you have two clubs
and they're kind of scattered there's
really
no it's weird when you're associated
with a club in the beginning like I was
associated with The Comedy Works in the
beginning and it was great they did
things I just wasn't ready for them when
I went to Seattle the underground also
gave me a [__] friendship and a
camaraderie that was
awesome awesome that's something that
I'll never ever forget those years with
Josh and the other guys and Brody and
Taya and what about like the of of being
on the road those early days with Rogan
and like not even like I'm sure I know
you and Rogan are close but like the
other openers like I've gotten pretty
close with J with Jacob just because
like you know we're there we chat when
he's on stage we watch his show together
sometimes we go to E like what was
what's being on tour like what were
those days like you know it's kind of
weird that I care a lot about a lot of
my friends but there's two guys in the
comedy world that I care a little bit
more than others and those two guys are
arish shaar and Duncan
truss we were Rogan's openers and even
red
band I know one thing in this
world I know one thing in this world
there's going to be one [__]
crying for sure at my funeral and that's
going to be
Redban Redban and me are very tight I
love Brian very much you know and Ari
like listen Ari's made some mistakes to
some people to others he's just a
[__] nut to me I know Ari like nobody
else because I know him as a child I
know him as a kid I know what his heart
is I saw him work I saw him get reject
rejected by Mitsy over and over I saw
him just break out one day and go [__]
all you [__] and he did the
Amazing
Racist and people still talk about it
people go listen whatever he is the
Amazing Racist was [__] tremendous he
did all that [__] then he sold that
character to a movie you know yeah guys
people have no idea my brother Duncan
Trussell again another guy that was the
talent coordinator at the store we were
friends before that when he became the
talent coordinator it was [__] club
Coco do you guys meet at the store how
did you meet with Rogan we met at the
store
okay I still remember a door guy telling
me that I still remember this night like
it was he was really young then and
Duncan Duncan was a kid I had to be I
don't know in my 40s maybe okay and
we're waiting to go up there used to be
a pay
phone at the bottom of the stairs and
this comic was working the door and he
was talking about how he he wasn't
getting as many spots as he wanted to
and Duncan was a talent coordinator at
the time and I was like 10 minutes away
from going on stage Duncan didn't know
this was going on when the kid came to
me I go you want more spots you didn't
know what you got to do here he goes
what sleep with mity I go no you gotta
pay The Vig
Jesus he goes whatat are you talking
about I go instead of taking the
$15 you got to pass the envelope to one
of us and we'll pass it to it goes back
there and he's like what if I want four
spots a week I go
then well you got to give him 60 bucks a
week and he goes when does this start
and I go next week if you want and right
there Duncan walked in he was the talent
coordinat at the time and I go
Duncan and he's like no please don't on
Duncan and I winked at Duncan I'm like
this guy wants more spots he says he'd
like to work something out where does he
leave his money he goes Duncan's like
leave it by the cash register on Fridays
and I'll take a look at it we'll see how
many spots you get a week bro we had
this kid going oh for like two hours
even after I got off stage he came up to
me so what about the main room how do I
get to the main I had this guy
going I was like oh that's for the
[__] belly room you want
oh that's
25 and he's like but what about the main
room that's like 150 all right I'll take
a main room we were [__]
dying that's the
best and look how how many shows are
like how many years were you on the road
with Ari and Duncan and red band had to
be five six years have years all because
we started doing it before 2007 with him
and then Rogan went on the men of Comedy
Tour okay that's where he met sagur and
those guys on the maximum man a comedy
tour and that was like we started
branching out after that because he was
gone for like six months so me and Ari
started doing little different things
and we would fill each other in I still
remember [__] calling
Ari in the middle of the afternoon and
going Ari I need 200 bucks and him going
come down to 200 South Le braa I'm here
right now auditioning there's an
envelope here I got 200 for you and he
go something else there's a commercial
here with your name on it's commercial
or something I ran down there I parked
my car Hari gave me the 200 I when I
signed up for the [__] commercial I
went in there and I booked
it and they're like who do we call and I
called AR I go all you got a commercial
agent he goes [__] yeah aqua and that's
how I got with aqua cuz you came with a
a gig yeah you show up with an envelope
like a real
Jew sometimes you got to show with an
envelope and that's exactly what I did I
signed with aqua talent agent that's
when Ari ran that [__] talent agency
yeah didn't he have get like a bunch of
commercials a bunch of them a bunch of
them in the beginning Hari was the king
of [__]
commercials I remember a keia one that's
it's so it gives me hope a little bit
but
it should give every comic hope listen
when you touch the stage as a young
comic an old
comic I don't care what anybody tells
you you're looking for
something there's something you're
actually looking for self-respect uh
trying to get back at Society you know
whatever whatever it is you want to be
famous you want to take pictures of with
[__] you know with uh Cat Williams
you know whatever the [__] it is that
you want to
do so it's a journey
man it's a [__] Journey you enjoy it
because what you're going to enjoy from
this journey is going to be completely
different than what you
think and in what like you think because
like for for me whatever the [__] you
think is gonna
happen whatever you want to happen will
probably happen not the path that you're
thinking you're gonna get
it and that's strong that's what really
makes you go what the
[__] I worked for this and I ended up
getting this I didn't want this I wanted
this but I got
this or it's [__] amaz you know I was
reading something about uh Clint
Eastwood couple mons about how you know
he had to leave the United States and go
to Italy and shoot movies
because nobody would hire him here and
then he would [__] come here and do
the the he would dub him in English they
would send them the reels because they
were made in Italian you know I didn't
know that yeah so it's just really weird
I I think everybody wanted him Charles
Bron and all those guys just wanted to
come up the American way when the
American way didn't give it to them they
went a different way and then came back
harder that's not they they didn't want
to live in Italy shooting [__]
Italian
movies but that was the journey and
that's what comedy is man comedy is a
fantastic Journey it's a growing
experience and it'll get you I don't
know it'll get you the self no matter
what level you get to everybody just
wants to be a [__] star today and
this is why with this book and what
we're doing here it's about stand up the
[__] podcast don't matter that's what
people think they want get into comedy
and do comedy 50% and stand up 50% you
got to pick a [__] evil either you're
going to be a podcaster or a [__]
comedian when I'm trying and you're
gonna go well Joey you did it hold on I
was established as a comic
already when I started podcasting I was
already 20 years into
comedy that's a hell of a [__]
cushion let's say 19 years into comedy
that's still a lot I had had movies
under my belt I had been on a set before
I knew how a set worked I knew how a lot
of things worked before I walked on a
podcast 20 that's 20 years it's what I
was thinking about earlier because it's
it's just I put so much work into I put
work into both but just the the way I'm
able to like see if it works on a on a
on standup but I I had something happen
this weekend that I wanted to talk to
you about because I never like my I'm
never I'm not a shock comic I'm not
really even that dirty but I made
someone Cry For the First Time like I I
don't know if she left I don't think she
actually left but like I like she was so
upset at my joke and like I didn't sleep
that night like I stayed up I I I was
GNA rewrite it like it it [__] really
hurt my like
no once you strike a cord [__] it run
with it you didn't go out there and put
from what I heard from what you told me
you didn't go out there and just go [__]
retards whatever you told the story
about a guy checking into a hotel right
telling the hotel that you were on the
Spectrum it was a joke on you right yeah
all of a sudden out of anywhere she
turned it into her night crying and I've
never been so insulted I got a kid away
pain chips that's not my that's not my
[__] problem I didn't insult him it's
not like I went up there and said I hate
kids who wear helmets or you know on the
Spectrum or whatever no no it's right
uh you have to you know listen man
sometimes a joke might hurt it's a funny
joke somebody listen as long as you're
not doing abortion Hitler jokes anti-jew
jokes you know there's so many [__]
things that uh you could be saying I
mean I've gone to places and the things
I've heard out of comics mouth and
you've heard [__] out of my mouth and
when I hear that coming out of I just
cringe sometimes oh yeah there's
definitely stuff but do you have like
how did you decide what your line was do
you have a line that you won't write
jokes about I know you just said like
you know abortion absolutely there's a
couple lines I won't pass and I'm sorry
as a comic I talked about this my the
first time I got on stage uh the night
that night that is a
comic 70 of us 70% of us are religious
so we're brought up religious or
whatever when I got into comedy there
was a line I wouldn't
cross I did Jesus jokes like a
[__] and whatever I laugh at
Kennison doing
them I didn't like the abortion reaction
from the
audience that was one thing I I didn't
ever want I didn't find any jokes in the
abortion of a baby or
uh Hitler jokes
or you know whatever like that I never
found that type of
stuff it's just some stuff that doesn't
even though I was crazy on stage and I
know I've said things that most people
won't [__] and say you know they look at
me and go Jesus Christ I would never say
that you
know there's a couple things and you'll
see it you have to read the
room and definitely reading the room but
it's all
also the part that like I was going and
Josh talked to me for a while about it
but that's never and I don't uh judge
anyone whose style is that but I've
never all almost all of my jokes are
making fun of me almost all my jokes
yeah no no no you're doing don't ever I
don't want anyone to feel bad though no
no and that's what that's what a
professional does you're looking the
[__] when you go to an open mic or you
go to a like a even at The Comedy Store
one night I was hosting
okay in the open mic and I was sitting
next to Mitsy out of the 20 Comics that
go up six of them have this thing
that it's the stanh Hope
effect they want to be Stan hope but
they didn't put the years in they don't
say it right they don't the delivery is
completely off and they go up there and
they want to be stanh hope and they
don't understand that I wish we could
tape it for them tape them saying the
jokes and the reaction from the a
audience it so what you got us with that
first one there was a point in my life
when I did that really you not to that
extreme punching bab or kicking the
soulle of an aborted
fetus don't want to hear that
[__] it's rough you know so once you see
it that it don't work there's a comic in
La I've known for 20
years and he's still doing this F
[__] same
joke and it is the worst joke I have
ever heard in my life the joke is bad
the noises he makes are bad the you it's
just a [__] long night and it's like
his longest bit it's like a seven minute
that he's had as a closer it didn't work
he moved into a [__] middle it didn't
work and he opens with it and that's
when people started running out of the
store and he stopped getting
sets Jesus for 20 years and then one day
I I got out of the store for like seven
years so I hadn't seen him so he's you
know on Facebook at the
time and he's writing that he's blowing
up this that this I kind of believe him
because people and La do blow up and
then we were put on a show together one
night somewhere and he did that [__]
joke eight years later he did the joke
that's still not working for him he
opened up with it and I could see
people's reaction and today I think he
works at a [__] Factory in the
valley do you ever have you ever said
anything to a comic about that or do you
not really bring up other people's jok
unless you're my [__]
brother unless you're my brother you
understand comedy how I
do you know people have come up to me
and said hey change that for a second do
I get offended I'm taking it from who
the [__] it is if it's some Open Mic who
can't get arrested I'm not taking his
[__]
advice I've never T listen in my life
somebody wrote a joke for me one person
said this joke would work for you and it
turned out the joke was stolen and a
bunch of [__]
hor yeah the guy accused me of a joke he
did 20 years ago I'm GNA do I don't even
know you this went on for about six
months and the dude died [__]
him someone gave you a stolen [__]
joke yeah yeah and it was a stupid joke
and one night I was in a pinch and I did
it and then it started working I was
like oh that joke works and then one day
I get [__] assaulted at The Improv
hey you sto my
joke I'm I haven't been accused I have
had I've seen a couple other Comics have
like the same it not that they stole it
from me by any means but like we had the
same joke and it bummed me out like I
don't really do that joke anymore listen
when you go to a comedy club right you
jokes are going to get stolen once in a
while when you go to an open mic they're
going to pick your [__] apart like a
buzzard on the
road [__] you've had have you had
something stolen no because I never had
jokes like that I never had good
jokes but when you're an open mic you'll
be doing comedy one day in [__]
Indiana okay and six years later
somebody will call you with a tape and
go look at this guy and you go holy [__]
he's doing my material bit by bit he's
some guy that works SE rooms he just
stole he he was in an open mic with you
damn he all your [__]
material you get mad add his flavor to
it just did word for
word I'd be pissed like I that's not
even something I've even thought about
yet have you ever like you've never said
anything to anybody about I don't want
you to think about it okay okay I don't
want you to think about it because
people get bent over over a stolen joke
okay if it's been if you know the
[__] stole it you look at him
you say a prayer for
him and know that he stole a [__]
joke and if he stole one joke he stole
five
jokes and right not today but in two or
three years it'll come out or something
else will happen he won't get to that
place well you were talking when you
were talking earlier about like you
wanted to know you did the work
something that I I not that I worry
about it but that's important to me and
I wonder if it's important to
you is I don't care I don't necessarily
need every comic to like me but I want
to be respected like I want to be
respected as a com does that at all play
into you like you want other Comics to
look you like yeah that's a good comic
I'm gonna tell you something how long
have you been doing comedy Lee five
years okay number one right now you're
very fortunate you have somebody face
you on the road but right now you'd be
you'd be getting into comedy clubs as an
MC couple clubs would be giving you Fe
your
spots I want you to stop being in your
[__] head what if a guy steals your
joke what if just do your
comedy when you're an early comic this
is what I want to stress do your comedy
don't worry about three months from now
or what's going to happen when somebody
steals my joke I'm not going to know
what to do listen write another
one okay you could take a month out of
your life wasting time and crying you
could just write another one that's even
better you know when you're a comic I
you cannot be in your head every day
what if with the what if cannot that's
that k a comic that stop it huh how do
you stop it just do a [__] set and
smoke
weed smoke more weed and do more sets I
want you to always think about where you
are and never
forget you're a fiveyear comic you're
five years away from you know in your
mind in your mind you were call Joe he's
wrong I could do this in seven years
listen in 10 five more years you'll be
in the rotation you'll be in New York or
[__] LA and let the let the game come
to you as it comes to you don't start
thinking about [__] like what am i g to
do when I get an agent listen if anybody
approaches you now they're full of [__]
okay because where they going to book
you they're going to
cancel uh [__] the Indian and put you
in there at the Improv the headline no
so anybody who comes to you with that
[__] now don't worry about any of that
[__] right now get into a
habit you know I went to Jiu-Jitsu
yesterday I was working with this guy
and he was young you know he was a new
white belt he had two stripes and he
kept grabbing me here and I said grab me
here he goes yeah but that I'm not going
to choke you go don't matter get in the
habit of sticking that hand deep in that
collar getting that habit now getting
that habit now is when you get these
habits in now is we spoke two weeks ago
about
writing you asked me what mistakes did
you make this is it you're a great
writer this time you're wasting on the
what ifs the Jeopardy
mind you're wasting your [__] time
right now your result is to do comedy
write comedy and log it down that's it
that's it you're going to step over that
and it's going to come back to fire you
stick to what you're doing right now
don't worry about 20 years from now
that's the best thing about a comic we
don't have to worry about it we're not
waiting for a promotion we're not
waiting for a raise you know when we get
all those things when we earn them
this is old school Jiu-Jitsu they're
saying every year I'm going to give you
a stripe or a belt that's the beauty
about [__]
comedy that you want to knock out of
this tax bracket yeah but it's gonna
take
time you know it's not going to happen
in six
months it's G to take time and plant
that in your head because I did and I'm
the most unpatient person in the
world I Knew by the time I got to
Seattle that this is going to take time
Jack holy
[__] this is GNA take a lot longer than
what I
anticipated what what how like what made
you realize
that just how much work you have to do
to get five minutes the [__] you got to
do the places you have to
sleep this ain't G to be easy you you
know this ain't gonna be when I used to
watch Rogan they would party in the
afternoons and and go eat dinner yeah
that that's not what it
is you guys saw the after
product you guys didn't see the
beginning
product
right and not that it seems easy because
I I never even when I was watching that
I didn't think it was
easy but it's like you know it's hard
for me to imagine you as like a a
20-year-old I don't know I just met you
when you were 50 no no no or 40
something and but I was even doing
comedy I was still Robbin clubs not
comedy clubs
so my mind at 30 was I had done
everything I had been a felon I was in
my mind I was a loser I didn't have
nothing going on so why not go into
something now that you really want to do
oh absolutely I I wasn't married I I
lost my child I had one bill every month
which was child support I didn't have a
car payment you know I barely paid
Insurance you know it was just something
that it worked at that time but there
was one day I realized
like this is just comedy your life is
[__]
standup the first 10 years and I want
people to know that it's not about head
shots and going to a Premiere and taking
your picture on the catwalk that's
that's all great but that ain't going to
do dick for you getting on stage and
writing those jokes and listening to
your sets that's gonna and get ready
that you're married to
Comedy but Joey I'm already married well
get ready for a mistress tell her that
sh because somewhere along the line
you're gonna have to put the work in
somewhere along the line you're going to
have to [__] get up at two: in the
morning and write till 4: somewhere
and this is not driven by money this is
driven by
habits this is why I tell you get in the
habit
now it's a lot easier I didn't take it I
used to write in the car driving
listening to music smoking little paper
and I would come up with a a subject and
then go on stage and rewrite the rest of
it that's why I didn't have a
career at the beginning yeah that's why
I was a mediocre feature act because I
would improvise and do stand up and
impro they got to know who the [__] you
are when you get into the nuts and bolts
they don't want to see a guitar they
don't want to see voices that's cute and
you could do a voice go on satday Night
Live this is you a stage bricks and a
microphone it's midnight and there's
eight people in
there right when you were living in your
ho in Indiana thinking that I can't wait
to go out to Hollywood I'm going to do
spots at the store and the guys will be
there the guys are
home it's you at 11:15 at the store for
six people this is not what you
thought you go home those nights and
you're like maybe it's time to go sell
apples with Dad you know what I'm saying
maybe it's time to get into the Family
Market that's where you test yourself
who the [__] you
are and you make a deal with yourself
you know what if I stick with this I got
to do more of this okay I'm going to
give myself six months in 6 months if
I'm not doing
this I'm going to [__] quit guess
what you won't hit that in 6 months but
something else will come
up that'll keep you in the
game if you keep working at it
that's and because you you had you
talked about with me like right before
we met you almost not fully equi but
went and got a
job listen man uh it's a
journey they're not going to give you
nothing and because of the success of
the podcast and what you
see with Joe Koy and Bert and Tom and
Rogan and fancy cars with a lot of
comics these people getting into this
and even podcasting people getting into
this thinking where's my $200 million
deal and then they realize that this is
called [__] work
man this is work this ain't no Michael
Jackson and this ain't [__]
Thriller
this week I'm going out
twice oh nice yeah that's my goal two
times this week that's it that'll put me
at four I got six more to decide what my
[__] fate
is and how how that week in like two
weeks in how's it going how was last
week
tremendous tremendous it was 7
Minutes of you didn't think I even
quit the energy was really I was happy I
was
enthusiastic and I was having fun
again I I had
fun what was it like the last seven
minutes of the set like where where was
it it was just fun you know the whole
set was fun I did the bit I did the week
before and added a new
bit so it was fun creating and then
taking it to the stage delivering it you
know it it's been really a lot of fun I
just finished putting three auditions on
tape I put an audition on tape yesterday
and one today and I got to put another
one tonight at some point you know for
uh three different two different
shows but you know it's like it's it's
nice that I had a day to look at these
and create one guy that I auditioned for
was a guy who owned a laundry place and
he gets questioned by the cops the other
guy is arrested Resturant owner and uh
this one I got to put tonight is for a
gangster but you know and it's great
thinking about the roles going on I
gotta wear a white shirt for that one oh
this one I'll let my hair messed up you
know this one I'll put a Met hat on and
put a a gold chain on or something so
all this creating stuff always is very
good for
you and I didn't have this for a while I
would get these auditions and I would
[__] dread them really even audition
you didn't yeah because you got to learn
the lines my mind wasn't retaining lines
I and then I started getting better at
them then I started getting like I was
like one out of every three were good
and now I'm getting back into it so
thanks for you for inspiring me you know
getting me on here once a week talking
about this [__] help me write a better
book so people could understand and you
know I just want people to understand
that they're confusing podcasting
with stand up don't confuse the two it's
two different complete different [__]
muscles and one will help the other one
in
time but for right now you need to focus
on the building blocks which is
standup and what do I always say I'm
thinking about doing standup but I
really write a want to write
something you're never gonna write
dick I'm gonna solve that right now for
you you're not going to write dick so
think about the day think about you
driving your mother to the doctor
whatever write it out and go up there
and just tell the story and see where
you could sprinkle it and that's your
first time on
stage you know that's it it's that
[__]
easy it is when you when you're doing it
but like making that jump there's a lot
I just remember because I'm I did it a
couple years ago it's
like there's just a lot of anxiety at
least for me like when you when you're
saying turn your brain off if I figure
out how to do that I'm gonna be sh it's
my whole life eat more [__] Edibles
my friend I've been telling you seven
[__] years what do you got this week
coming up tan I'm ex I'm going to
Nashville for the first time I'm doing
it's gonna be my first time doing an
hour I'm gonna be at the East room on
the 19th at 7 pm I'm very excited and
then you got two shows or something or
just one one show Friday one show
Saturday Saturday is I'm just doing a
local Nashville show I'm not even sure
where that is yet I I'll put that up
online when I find out but if you could
come out take it to 10 bucks at the East
room I'm just I'm excited to do an hour
for the first time I've hit 40 minutes I
want to see if I can do 20
more and I'm just [__] really excited
are you taping them oh yeah I I bring a
I have a I bought a phone to film it I
filmed this weekend in Richmond I uh
I listen I always do audio but I'm I've
been trying to film them recently film
now so you can watch the watch the body
language learn what you're looking maybe
twist to your head this is becomes
interesting watching tape that's a
complete different episode we'll talk
about I was not good at watching tape
but whenever I did have the courage to
watch three two minutes I would always
go holy [__] I gotta do something
I gota way I gotta stop twitching I
gotta stop moving you know so that's
what's good about [__] tape my
friend I I well I'll save it for that
episode but yeah it's I I've noticed a
lot I've started I tried to do on
Saturday because I I used to just have
the leave in the mic in the mic stand
for like the first three like up until
like six months ago and then I started
to take it out and I'm trying to start
to move around a little bit I never
really moved
and like it's crazy how like the I have
a joke now where I look and I like I'm
just starting to act stuff out a little
bit I've never really but it's crazy how
it can get laughs it's just a movement
can get a laugh this is
it this is it for me it was using my
hands when I first started I would move
and I'd make you [__] dizzy and I
could see I stop moving I'm right there
I'm a Target I got my hands explaining
the joke it's like I'm a [__] Cuban
sign
reader but yeah I'm looking forward to
this week's sets nice I'm congratulating
you on an hour I'm sure I'll hear about
it that night oh yeah and that's it we
just covered another week of [__] the
checking this is what we would do on the
phone so yeah I love it I'm having a
great time on Monday nights talking
about this and it excites me as you
could tell it gets me angry this is one
of the only things I ever cared about
man right film and [__] like this
it's one of the only things that I
really dove into film is the second
let's face it I I love everything about
film but again when I first started I
thought film and standup were the
same and they weren't and it was just an
extension so your big muscle is standup
TV films commercials podcast that's all
extensions of your muscles that's what
makes you a
superhero but the building
block is what we discuss [__] I
love it thank you buddy I love these
talks me too I love these two I don't
give a [__] if two people get it some
comic is gonna come up to me one day and
go hey I heard that episode and you were
right or you were wrong or thank you for
doing this and this is what uh a laboral
love is all about I love it buddy great
to talk to you all right we'll talk
during the week have a great week you
too
[Music]
the checkin is brought to you by my
favorite liquid IV new year new you it's
time to drink something other than booze
and get your hydration on point liquid
IV lets you rehydrate easily just pour
the packet into a glass of water Shake
It Up and that's it liquid IV comes in
tons of awesome flavors my favorite is
golden cherry I love the grape they got
sugar free and lemon lime white peach
and the green grape will knock you off
your [__] socks liquid IV is ready to
take you from a dehydrated mess to a
brand new you I get up in the morning I
blast off a liquid ivena before I drink
coffee to get all the spirits out of my
system and I'm ready to go so R 2024 is
the year to rehydrate yourself so do do
yourself a favor grab liquid IV
hydration multiplier sugarfree in bulk
nationwide at Costco who I love or I'm
Gonna Get You 20% off your first order
when you go to liquid
i.com use code Joey at checkout that's
20% off your first order when you shop
better hydration today using promo code
Joey at liquid
i.com again liquid i.com C Joey the
checkin is also brought to you by factor
maybe you wait like trash in December
well that was last year and this is this
year Jack we got a whole new thing going
on eat well with Factor the meal kit
that does all the work for you no
grocery shopping no chopping vegetables
no piles of dirty dishes to deal with
Factor sends you a fresh restaurant
quality meal right to your doorstep all
you got to do is heat them up for two
minutes that's it and they're ready to
eat they're tremendous they have over 35
meals to choose from every week vegan
vegetarian keto options and more this
beats eating three-day old meal prep
casserole trust me what I'm telling you
so Factor even has snacks you can take
with you breakfast smoothies and juices
to keep you going all day head over to
factor meals.com that's factor meals.com
and use Diaz 50 and I'm going to get you
50% off that's that's right that's code
diaz5 at factor meals.com
diaz5 to get
50% off the checkin is also brought to
you by B bam blue Chu listen it's time
to go to Vegas and bust a nut Jack you
know what I'm saying it's bluechew time
for you Savages blue is an online
service that delivers Ed medicine with
the same AC ingredients as Viagra seis
and Levitra right to your door they come
in chewable tablets tremendous just pop
one 30 to 60 minutes before getting down
and dirty and forget about it that
muffler will be completely different you
could take them any time breakfast lunch
dinner and it's easy to get a
prescription just sign at blu.com and
talk to one of the licensed medical
providers and you'll get your
prescription within days blueo wants to
have you have better sex all right
that's it they want you to be a [__]
Savage so discover your options at
blue.com chew it and do it Jack and get
a special deal for the check-in
listeners you ready try blue Chu for
free it's free it's [__] Tuesday I'm
hooking you up Prest in COD Joey Joe y
at checkout just pay $5 for shipping
that's blu.com promo code Joey to
receive your first month free visit
blu.com
for more details and important safety
information and I want to thank them for
sponsoring the checkin